we can make a deal right here right now
sorry we don't negotiate
I'll make it the stead curses on screen
olive on the walking dead man lakum
half-elf bear Fox
hey youtubers it's Charlie so there are
all kinds of f bombs being dropped we
just got our first peek at negan this is
actually like an international promo
that supposedly leaked early I don't
know whatever it's Jeffrey Dean Morgan
as the negan character one of the few
advantages to having international shows
is that when they drop promos you get
different footage depending which part
of the world the promo dropped in so if
you've never read the comic you have no
idea who the nican character is he's
just one of the biggest characters that
the comic book has ever introduced he's
like the ubermensch Evelyn's when Robert
Kirkman introduced him in issue 100 of
the comic he said that it was meant to
be this big sign to the fans that there
was still all kinds of crazy stories
lots of stuff coming down the road
usually by the time a new interesting
comic gets to issue 100 it feels a
little burnt out
Robert Kirkman was like hell no we still
have plenty of awesome stuff coming so
he introduced negan as a way to tell
people that let's just look at the
footage in the promo though it seems
like there's gonna be some sort of
cliffhanger in Scott Gimple the
showrunner has said that they're going
to be very faithful to the comic so if
you want to run out and read what ends
up happening when negan first appears
you can pick up volume 17 something to
fear that picks up right around where
the Dwight stuff happened from last
week's episode what I think might be
happening is is that because there's a
rumor that they're gonna end on a
cliffhanger they might end on the stuff
that happens during issue 100 so be
careful for spoilers please don't post
spoilers in the comic because it is
going to be an awesome episode of TV
meanie that I think season 7 will
largely do vol 18 of the comic so if you
want to read vol 17 this week while you
get ready for the finale next week then
you can read while you made after the
finale just to get ready for season 7
because they are sticking pretty close
to the comics they do change a lot of
things I know a lot of people are
wondering who's gonna die next just
remember that there are some people on
the show that are alive now that died a
long time ago in the comics so just when
it comes to deaths it's really hard to
predict who they're gonna kill next but
usually when they do kill people they do
it in the way that it happened in the
comics so let's talk about negan a
little bit he's being played by Jeffrey
Dean Morgan which is sounds so awesome
most of you will probably recognize him
as the comedian from Watchmen also a
very messed up sadistic character
but he also played Bruce Wayne's dad
during the flashback in Batman V
Superman with lauren cohan playing
Martha Wayne so if you go see Batman V
Superman this weekend you can see negan
married to Maggie which i think is
hilarious
in the comics we all know negan is the
leader of the saviors but before the
apocalypse this is actually really funny
he was a used car salesman so that
should give you an idea for some of his
personality of course the worst human
being on the planet used to be a car
salesman you have no idea how bad you're
gonna feel about yourself when you laugh
at what he says he's genuinely funny
he's a used car salesman so he is a
master at slinging [ __ ] he'll just
go on long speeches and lead you along
and then just tell you that he was
messing with you the whole time
you never really know what his character
is doing and he is super charismatic I
mean I mean look at Jeffrey Dean Morgan
of course he's charismatic but the negan
character was always written that way so
you have any friends who quit the show
now is the time to tell them to sit
their ass in front of their TV and
prepare for negan there are a lot of
people that quit the show when Shane was
killed off I think that they'll come
back for Meighan and the cool thing
about this is that negan is just the
beginning there's so much more they've
been teasing that this season you're
part of a bigger world now so there are
even more big comic book characters that
I think that will see in season 7 but
please use spoiler tags if you have read
ahead in the comics and you want to talk
about them so let me know in the
comments do you think they're gonna use
the issue 100 WTF with negan as a
cliffhanger for next season I feel like
that's what they've been talking about
Gimple has been like we're gonna be very
faithful to the comic there's gonna be a
big WTF cliffhanger it will tell the
world that they need to be watching
Walking Dead I feel like there's really
only like one or two things they could
do but they might swap out some of the
characters that end up being a part of
that like I said Walking Dead does do
moments ripped right off the comic book
page but sometimes it'll swap comic book
characters in and out for whatever that
scene ends up being so I'll post my
episode 15 video after it air saw be
sure to subscribe to get that there'll
be a new round of the giveaway I'm
working on a new Game of Thrones video
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
there's still some Batman V Superman
stuff that I want to do but some of that
might end up rolling into Monday just
because there's so
much stuff happening right now between
Walking Dead Batman V Superman in Game
of Thrones in case you guys didn't see
it yesterday there was a new game of
Thrones footage that dropped you can
click here for my breakdown of that and
you can click here for my Batman V
Superman Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight